I want to compliment you you always look
good you got good hair I'm gonna
compliment your hair it's going a little
bit though how's it going
yeah I've been losing it since I it's
like I mean if I really get up in there
guys I mean it's like starting to
disappear right so I when I was like 25
I noticed it was starting to go and so I
went to me I went and met the guy the
doctor haired guy doctor and he was like
he put me on this at this medication
called avodart and he ever heard of this
town so anyway it's like a finesse to
ride and it and what's that wait now now
I need to know what that so basically
connects ride it's like Hydrox adil yeah
so your blood glucose I made what I
don't know what it is so your body
produces testosterone and then some do
some don't so heavily testosterone Aidid
doesn't work any which way the byproduct
of testosterone actually cause follicles
to get weaker fall out and so you take
this stuff and it washes away the the
byproduct of testosterone right but we
don't know what else that might be used
being used for that could be good in the
body but anyways right so I've been like
holding onto the hair pretty good right
but then we decided that we're gonna
have children I didn't know what you
know was it okay is it safe to take when
you maybe maybe shouldn't be on that if
you're trying to have a baby yeah so I
stopped taking the stuff about three
years ago and now I'm experiencing the
hair loss right it's like it's starting
to go right I'm a baseball cap guy so I
think I'm okay right I'm like thirty
what I've established myself is like
this baseball cap wearing individual
your you're always wearing a baseball
cap so you're gonna be fine but it does
go you're not gonna know that it's gone
because I'm still I'm just gonna have
the ball cap on would you ever go the
like you know like a fake hair root
would you ever do that no I'm no toupee
I'll just let it go I'll go I'll go like
character actor or something yeah I
think that's the way to go I think it
must be such a pain in the I mean this
thing is velcro it's that easy it just
comes off it makes a ripping sound and
then goes right back or you go ball cap
and then Pete and then you don't know
but now you're you haven't established
yourself as a ball cap guys and I look
terrible in a baseball cap and what are
you gonna wear like a paper boy hat and
be like hey guys
did you have a nose yeah that I can't do
that whenever and I do wear those caps
around and people do want to buy like an
apple from me for a dime sunny come here
I'll buy an apple oh sure thanks mister
that's not a good way to go it's just
gonna be trouble so you're saying that
the more tests the less testosterone you
have the more hair you have generally
speaking I would think relative to this
science that I don't know much about so
insulting
all right I don't I really don't I'm not
a scientist I don't know wait you're not
a scientist not officially not aside all
these years I go with all these big
finasteride words I just Wikipedia
that's me renowned scientist Ashton
Kutcher I have questions
you